good afternoon everybody welcome to
today's press conference my name is jp
tasker from cbc news and i'll be today's
moderator
i have here sean frazier the minister of
immigration refugees and citizenship and
filippo grande the united nations high
commissioner for refugees gentlemen the
floor is yours please take it away
uh thank you so much it's a pleasure to
uh to be here with you uh bon apres
media good afternoon everyone um i'm
absolutely honored uh to be joined here
by my uh my friend felipe grandi the
united nations high commissioner for
refugees uh high commissioner grandi and
unhcr have been amongst canada's
strongest partners in our global
humanitarian efforts and i want to
deeply and publicly thank you for for
your support
uh now spending many years uh high
commissioner grandi and i today
discussed both canada's plans to welcome
visitors fleeing the war in ukraine as
well as country's ongoing commitment to
welcome afghan nationals to canada
canada
on ukraine
working with partners we're going to
continue to do everything that we can to
make sure ukrainians are supported over
the course of their stay in canada since
january 1st more than 12 000 ukrainians
have arrived here in canada and over the
past two weeks since launching
applications for the new expedited
process the canada ukraine authorization
for emergency travel we've now received
more than 112 000 applications
from individuals who are seeking to come
to canada and in the last number of days
we have now approved more than twenty
six thousand five hundred
convolutions
to support canada's response we acted
early
this includes streamlining our
processing and visa requirements while
prioritizing the safety and security of
canadians at the same time
to reduce the pressure on biometrics
collection we're accepting biometrics
for uh certain individuals from low-risk
cohorts including
youth up to the age of 18.
people over the age of 60 as well as
those who have a travel history to
canada who've
followed the rules in previous previous
visits
again these decisions regarding
biometric exemptions have been taken
with great care because we want to make
sure that we
maintain the confidence of canadians
that we have a process in place
that both expedites the arrival of
ukrainians and doesn't compromise on the
the important security outcomes of the
biometrics assessment
even though most are arriving as
temporary residents we announced
recently that we would also expand uh
settlement support for all ukrainians
coming to canada in recognition of the
special circumstances that they're
facing this means ukrainians will have
access to key services to help them
settle into their new communities this
will include things like language
training employment assistance services
for women seniors youth and lgbtq2 plus
persons
but it also includes in many instances
the soft supports that allow a person to
do well after they arrive in canada
sometimes it's little things like
making sure that people understand how
to sign their kids up for a soccer club
or how to ride the bus and sometimes
it's big things like providing child
care while parents are undertaking
language training supports
new zealand
services
i also want to highlight starting this
month
the canadian red cross with support from
the government of canada is providing
ukrainians with arrival packages at
initially at toronto vancouver and
edmonton airports these packages include
key information on supports and services
as well as information in ukrainian
venice
a new continue
in the city of
i want to make clear
that notwithstanding the enormous effort
that we're putting behind ukraine
we also remain extremely committed to
helping those we've made a commitment to
in afghanistan last week i had the
privilege of greeting a chartered flight
at pearson international airport with
nearly 300 privately sponsored refugees
this marked an important milestone in
canada's resettlement initiative with
respect to afghanistan
because it marked the arrival of of 10
000 afghan refugees
since the beginning of the humanitarian
crisis uh i i should also point out that
earlier today
an additional flight arrived in calgary
with more than 330 afghan refugees who
will now be given a second lease on life
uh here in canada uh in fact when i was
in calgary just a couple of weeks ago i
had the good fortune of bumping into a
recently arrived afghan refugee on the
street who recognized me and wanted to
say thank you to canada after a short
conversation and an expression of
gratitude and a hug to welcome him to to
to our country um 90 seconds later he
found
seven or eight friends who arrived on
the same flight and came running down
stephen avenue i used to live in calgary
and i'm attached to the city and um it's
a moment i'm never gonna forget
um
these are people who just got out of
quarantine it was i think their first or
second day uh that they were actually
allowed to explore canada and i was one
of the first people they bumped into
uh
and it gave me faith
that we're doing the right thing to make
a substantial commitment uh to those
who've
fled the taliban in afghanistan and are
now living in canada
um
being able to welcome personally those
who arrived on the plane to pearson last
week
it was an incredible moment
i you know i put it into perspective uh
for myself
ten thousand people um
i live in the town of new glasgow
there are fewer than 10 000 people live
in the town of new glasgow
to think of my entire community
is represented in the scale of the
people who've already arrived in canada
and that we're going to continue to go
to 40 000 is extraordinary to me
but what really struck with me
stuck with me is the um
like you see kids when you're a parent
and you see kids the same age as your
own kids
who might not remember what it was like
to live under taliban rule um i've had
the chance to meet a number of kids
who've come to canada's refugees that
are common are adjusting to life in
canada the same way that my kids are
and it's it's an extraordinary thing
to see the
the difference that that this program is
going to make in their lives
the stories of these newcomers don't end
with the
with the arrival of an airplane you know
they come to canada in communities large
and small that are welcoming afghans
with open arms
objectives
i want to emphasize that we remain
seized with this effort and are going to
continue to work with provinces and
territories resettlement
settlement service providers private
sponsors and other stakeholders welcome
additional afghan refugees
refugees
today we had the opportunity to join
leaders from other nations around the
world and international organizations to
launch an exciting new initiative that
i'm very proud of and that's the global
task force on refugee labor mobility and
i'm very honored that canada is serving
as the inaugural chair of this task
force
we're going to engage with global
stakeholders from government businesses
ngos and civil society to increase the
number of skilled refugees that are
welcome to canada while decreasing labor
shortages where canada needs it most
this initiative builds off a
groundbreaking program
that is born and bred here in canada the
economic mobility pathways pilot or empp
as we we call it for sure
is a program that recognizes the skills
and abilities of refugees and allows
them and their families to immigrate to
canada through existing economic
programs what it really allows us to do
is level the playing field for refugees
who are forced to flee their countries
through no fault of their own by
providing an alternative pathway to
canada and this pathway is complementary
to our resettlement efforts that allow
canada to do even more to help some of
the millions of displaced people around
the world so it's over and above the
existing humanitarian commitments that
we've made
through the emp
we're on track this year to resettle
over 500 refugees but
i do have the intent to significantly
expand expand this program in the years
ahead to attract thousands of more
refugees or displaced talent
to canada while upholding our proud
humanitarian commitments
i've seen this program work in my
community there's a business and not a
business a long-term care facility
glenn haven manor it's five minutes from
my home
there's a cohort of employees who were
trained as health professionals abroad
who happen to be refugees
but they were brought to become health
care workers in our community through
economic streams
they're allowing my friends parents to
receive care in the community where they
have lived for many years these are
people who are making an enormous
difference i think to myself despite the
fact that we've recovered more than 112
percent of the jobs lost during the
pandemic before the omicron variant
landed in our communities there was over
900 000 job vacancies
the opportunity that we have before us
to use this program to change the way
that the world thinks about refugees not
just as people who are in need of
need of assistance though they are very
much that as well but people who can
make an immense contribution to our
communities make our communities more
vibrant and dynamic places to live this
is the opportunity that is staring the
world on the face and canada as part of
this global task force is going to seize
this opportunity
on our legislative programs
um high commissioner grandi and i i
think will agree uh the actions that
i've discussed today uh continue
canada's long tradition of humanitarian
contributions around the world
they demonstrate our ongoing commitment
to sharing responsibility for the
world's displaced and the world's
persecuted
again it's an absolute honor to have
high commissioner grandi visiting with
us and i now invite him to say a few
words thank you merci to the moment
conference
[Music]
and
for me it's
it was very important to
be able to
visit canada again
because as minister fraser already
mentioned
the partnership between canada and unhcr
has been and continues to be
a very important one i we just met with
the prime minister and
i told him that you know i became high
commissioner just after he was elected
prime minister the first time in
at the end of 2015 and
since then i
as the head of an organization that has
to face huge challenges i have
really been able to always count on
canada
for support
canada is one of our
10 top
state donors
with in the last couple of years an
average of about 100 million canadian
dollars contributed to unhcr this is a
sizable contribution which has been
growing in the past few years and this
really helps us
support refugees and displaced people
around the world
and of course canada is
a very important resettlement country
and minister fraser already spoke
about
different aspects of it resettlement
program
you know during
the past few years
when the us government
reduced
its resettlement program
it was canada that kept resettlement
alive as a solution and option for
refugees and i want to really take this
opportunity to thank canada we're very
happy that now the united states are
back with a very sizable resettlement
program but we could keep in place the
structures and the
and the and the programs because of
canadian support and canadian
persistency and
and
and
sustained
management of the resettlement program
it was the syrians i remember in my
first visit here the 25 000 syrians then
that came
uh
minister fraser mentioned the afghan
resettlement program in which we are
also cooperating
it is now
not a resettlement program but the
hospitality that is given to ukrainians
but let's not forget resettlement is
also about many other populations or
many other refugees in distress
particularly vulnerable in many other
places so that's very very important and
i want to commend all these
initiatives i would like to add that of
course with the prime minister and then
with in other government meetings
i have and will continue to discuss some
of the most acute
humanitarian and refugee crisis around
the world
you know
up to the 24th of february this year
my organization
counted
84 million refugees
and displaced people around the world
you all know that since then that number
has probably grown to well over 90
million we must be
in the region of 95 million now we
haven't the latest count but you know
that the ukrainian
war the russian invasion and the war
that has followed and
the exodus of people both outside
4.3 million people that have fled from
ukraine into neighboring countries and
the more than seven million that are
displaced inside making this the fastest
growing
and most dramatic refugee crisis in
europe since the second world war as we
have already said many times and i'm
grateful to canada for the support that
it is
providing
also through my organization in helping
refugees
helping displaced people inside ukraine
and trying to find solutions for them i
have recently visited for the second
time
poland uh previously i had also visited
moldova and romania some of the most
affected countries this time just last
week i was able also to
enter ukraine and visit western ukraine
where the displacement situation is very
serious we have seen a decrease in
recent days of the outflow of people
most likely because
ukrainians are watching very carefully
the evolution of military
the military offensive
and of the war
and uh
it is also possible that if
larger parts of ukraine um go back in
government control and
uh are stabilized that we will see also
some people going back but the scenarios
remain many very open many people are
asking me what do you think more people
will come we don't know this has been a
very unpredictable situation and i think
we need to be flexible in our response
on the humanitarian side to help people
where they need to be helped and this is
this includes of course ukraine itself
we have large programs there together
with other humanitarian agencies and it
includes also those cities that are
besieged and bombed and isolated you
have certainly followed the very very
excruciating negotiations
that the red cross
and the united nations humanitarian
agencies are conducting to have access
to those
places to bring supplies
to desperate people and to help
those that want to get out of those
traps literally
in every way we can very very
challenging work
very difficult to get guarantees that
those convoys will be
secured but we will continue to do that
in the spirit of helping people where
they need to be helped now of course and
this was
a message that i passed to the
prime minister and to the government of
canada not that they don't know that but
i think it's useful collectively to
remember that we cannot forget all other
crises in the world afghanistan is one i
was also very recently in my second
visit to kabul
uh after the taliban takeover in last
summer in august
and of course and even beyond
afghanistan yesterday i was in new york
i met
the
ambassadors of the african countries to
the united nations collectively and
their message was very strong please
don't neglect
us you know there's many crises in
africa humanitarian crisis there is a
need to be to sustain development
assistance there's a need to address the
devastating effect of climate change
and this has been a strong message to
the prime minister which of course was
very well heard and very much agreed
with
and i was very pleased to learn just
this morning that
the government of canada has
approved a substantive contribution to
humanitarian activities in the sahel
region of west africa and including
activities to address forced
displacement and i think this is really
important i know it's asking a lot to
countries with resources but we live in
a very in a very challenging world with
many different challenges with just
we're just emerging from the pandemic
we have now the ukraine crisis and an
important point to make is that
everything is connected you know very
well that the crisis in ukraine the war
sorry i should say the invasion and the
war in ukraine have caused are already
causing
enormous
problems on
food supplies around the world
on
energy supplies
with an impact that is particularly felt
on poor and fragile countries so
the
dealing with one crisis doesn't mean
that we need to neglect the others on
the country we need to have a very
interconnected approach to all these
different challenges
um
and i i am also grateful to the
government of canada for the attention
that it continues to pay
to humanitarian and displacement
problems in central america this is a
point that the prime minister just
raised with us reaffirming the
commitment of canada to contribute to
initiatives that are meant to address on
the one hand problems of violence in
central america that displace many
people but also economic and social
problems that require large investments
in order to offer people alternatives to
unnecessary migration so i'm very
grateful we have you know unhr has an
initiative in the
in that region not a big initiative but
a an important one and canada is one of
its main supporters and will continue to
be i want to conclude by saying uh
two things one is that
um to join uh sean fraser in applauding
this initiative of labor mobility for
refugees this is a fantastic
initiative as i said at the launch of
the
of the group that will lead this
initiative this morning this afternoon
you know the message is refugees carry
more than their suitcase carry skills
carry innovation capacity enthusiasm
eagerness to belong and contribute and
this initiative covers all these
important points so i hope actually that
it will be scaled up and replicated in
other parts of the world and we will
find ways to uh to
to do that and finally to say that
this is a bit personal if you wish but i
had an immense privilege this morning to
be invited by minister fraser to a
citizenship ceremony it was a virtual
one
but
i i said this to the prime minister just
a few minutes ago it was one of the most
moving
events that i have ever witnessed
perhaps because i deal with uprooted
people and i have dealt with uprooted
people for 40 years almost now you know
to witness the moment in which they're
not uprooted anymore and become citizens
of a
country where there is freedom and
prosperity and hope
was and will remain one of the great
moments for me in my life i'll never
forget it thank you very much
okay thank you both for your
presentation we'll now take about 20
minutes of questions if you have a
question line up at either of the mics
on the sides of the room here um if
you're on zoom please raise your hand
and we'll try and get to you after we
work through the people that are here in
the room so we'll start with david aiken
at global news please thank you david
aiken global news uh hi commissioner
minister good to see you both thank you
for taking our questions um you
referenced that we canada is dealing
really with two big refugee crises right
now ukraine and afghanistan recently
i've been speaking to a lot of advocates
for afghanistan refugees advocates for
those trying to get over here advocates
for those here
and they are worried that canada
may not have the capacity to deal with
such two huge crises so i wondered
minister if you could address that
concern that we don't have the capacity
to deal with these two crises and high
commissioner i wonder you just mentioned
84 million displaced people to nearly 95
million displaced people
what does that do to your organization
in terms of trying to help so many
people and so many new millions of
people all at once the capacity issue
gentlemen if you wouldn't mind thanks
uh thanks uh david for your your
question and
of course
the challenges facing uh immigration
canada are not complicated only by uh
the the two humanitarian crises that
you've mentioned
uh but but also by the challenges that
we've seen uh that stemmed from the
impact of coven 19 on on immigration
both from the impact on our operations
at offices around the world that have
been shut down due to public health
measures
in other countries where people don't
necessarily have the ability to work
from home the way they did in canada but
also the decision to
pivot towards welcoming more permanent
residents who were already in canada at
a time when the borders were closed
while applications kept coming in
there's never been more demands
on our immigration system in canada
but to answer your question when i think
about do we have the capacity to make
good on these commitments i don't think
we have the capacity not to um we made a
commitment uh to
people on the basis of a moral
obligation that we hold in afghanistan
who've
made a contribution that was significant
and enduring to canada during our
mission in afghanistan
and canada is a country that doesn't go
back on its commitments um
i'll
park my thoughts on on the value that
these newcomers are going to bring to
our country because i've addressed those
in my remarks to a certain degree
with respect to ukraine
i think to myself these are people who
are willing to lay down their lives to
defend the principles of sovereignty of
territorial integrity of
self-determination of peoples the very
right to choose
who gets to have a say in decisions that
impact your lives um
we don't have to
fight on the front lines of war on the
other side of the world to defend those
values at home
one of the things that we can do to
ensure that our allies in eastern europe
and across the european continent to
continue to have the capacity to
absorb people who are seeking safe haven
is to take some of that
responsibility in canada
we have an extraordinary
ukrainian-canadian community three
percent of canadians claim ukrainian
heritage um
there's people in need but there are
people who can be well supported in
canada
it's going to be a challenge
there's no question the challenges are
unique in afghanistan the challenges are
driven less by the capacity of our
department and more by the fact that the
territory has been seized by the taliban
a listed terrorist entity in canadian
law securing safe passage even for those
who have already been processed
by our department
is still enormously difficult when
you're seeing what life is like for them
on the ground
with respect to ukraine
we had the opportunity to start
preparing in advance as of january 19th
we struck up an internal task force at
ircc
and that early planning is is starting
to pay dividends i've mentioned we've
now i created a new program that's
approved 26 500 people to come here um
but that's in addition to the people who
were approved under the expedited
processing we had in place for others
the fact that we set up early not just
by getting people at the ready but
sending people and resources like
biometric kits into the region
is making it easier for us to handle
this and we built the system through our
visitors
regime that has the capacity typically
to process two million cases a year uh
so is it a challenge it's an enormous
challenge we're asking the system to do
more than it's ever been required to do
at a time when it's already facing
pressures uh but can we do it uh i don't
think we have a choice but to do it
before i answer your question just to
strengthen what
shaun just said a few moments ago
you know for
not here in canada but in europe for
many years we heard the argument that
it was impossible to take refugees too
difficult too many too complicated
you know famously chancellor merkel in
2015 said it's not true we can do it you
know she said they have shuffled us we
can do it and to me that remains you
know that that has remained a guiding
slogan for me in dealing with
governments and say if there is a will
to help people in extreme distress
there is a way to do it
and what europe is doing today uh with
ukrainian refugees by giving them what
they call temporary protection which is
a very expedited way to take them into
the different countries what canada is
doing through visitors program approach
demonstrate that when there is a will
there is a way to help people in
expedited way at the same time i know
that there's been a lot of discussion
here in canada about you know too slow
process for
the intake of african refugees at the
same time it's important especially when
it comes to resettlement to safeguard
the
these this process to ensure that they
are fair that the right people are are
benefit from resettlement and that you
don't rush it in a manner that makes it
unsustainable so you have to strike a
balance always between urgency and at
the same time integrity and and
sustainability of the program and just
to say that you know i salute canada's
commitment in all these areas and my
organization will continue to be a
partner in these efforts and to your
other question um
big challenges you know we are we are
moving towards maybe having a hundred
million uprooted people around the world
we're not we thought that it will take
many years to get there and maybe we
would never get there but unfortunately
this war
is getting us closer and what does that
mean it means that mobilizing resources
becomes more and more difficult
uh it means that
you know
we we have to we risk having some of the
crisis forgotten and neglected and these
are issues of great concern to us now on
the resources one point that i would
like to make and we'll discuss this more
tomorrow with minister sajan as well
is that
what all these crises show the
interlinkage between conflict climate
inequalities
in the past it was more straightforward
you have a humanitarian crisis you
respond with humanitarian resources
today you have to work in an
interdependent way we work for example
more and more with the world bank we
never did before because we want to
address some huge development issues
you know the the the prime minister of
poland told me in my first visit there
after the beginning of the war he said
yes we need humanitarian assistance but
we also need to start thinking how to
include hundreds of thousands of
children in our schools even a european
country has to think about how to
strengthen its education system to
absorb this huge influx and all the more
so countries that are poorer and do not
have those resources so that's the
resource challenge that we're facing but
the other one and i conclude the other
big one is of course the other big
concern that i have is the paralysis of
conflict resolution mechanism look at
what's happening in new york at the
security council and unfortunately
ukraine has put this crisis squarely on
the table of world leaders and i do hope
that at least
one silver lining of this
tragedy that is consuming itself in
ukraine will be a reflection on how you
know collectively we revitalize
uh peace mechanism that uh
are failing us big time and are failing
these people that then for whom then we
have to resort to aid or resettlement or
other emergency measures
uh thank you very much a follow-up for
minister fraser um so we received some
memos that your deputy wrote in august
to your predecessor minister mendocino
talked about the response to the
afghanistan situation it was a
situation caught everybody kind of by
surprise
and uh in it deputy minister tapley said
to minister manuccino we're going to
have to take some resources away from
our other lines of business to put them
on call lines and other things to deal
with afghanistan
so similarly would again this is
afghanistan
afghan refugee advocates they're worried
that that's what happened when the
ukraine crisis came out of nowhere is
your department had to take resources
away from other
lines of business other programs to deal
with ukraine can you speak to how
internally
you would have managed to keep up with
all you were doing on afghanistan and
then bring on all this ukrainian stuff
because last time around it's pretty
clear resources had to be diverted from
existing programs causing slowdowns and
other immigration streams yeah thanks
for that um for that question it's
important one and i think you got to
appreciate when you ask a system to do
more um it
it requires you to respond and
reallocate resources in in a short term
uh if you're dealing with an emergency
but to be absolutely clear um
the resources are put in place to ensure
that you can uh you can accommodate
those adjustments you've had to make so
the prime minister announced with
respect to ukraine uh 117 million dollar
contribution to stand up the programs
that we've now put in place to make sure
that we're able to uh backfill those
resources to ensure that we don't
compromise the outcomes that are so
important to canada's interest whether
it's from a humanitarian resettlement
point of view in afghanistan or the
ordinary operations of our uh
immigration system
we're not just putting more more money
at it we've actually been borrowing
staff where we can from other government
departments to make sure that we're
accommodating
to whatever extent possible uh the the
need to respond very very quickly while
at the same time making sure we put a
plan in place to uh backfill those
resources so we don't compromise
outcomes um in the the days and weeks
following a crisis emerging certainly
there can be
a short-term impact if you're asking the
same worker to do uh twice as much
that that's not a sustainable or or fair
way to operate
but we do
accommodate that kind of a situation by
by putting resources in place so we're
not asking the system to do more than it
can handle given the resources available
to it
um mr fraser i want to ask you about the
fcfo and other francophone
organization yesterday they asked the
federal to boost to increase the targets
for francophone outside go back to 12 in
2024 and 20 in 236
knowing that we haven't been able to
reach 4.4 since 2003 do you think that
12
in two three years is feasible
[Music]
um
these measures are starting to have an
impact um i do
expect after several years of work to
to work towards the goal of 4.4 percent
uh that we're going to be able to
achieve that uh
this uh i i i welcome the report uh we
now need to do some deep thinking on
what we need to do i i think the
starting point for me is that
um
as somebody grew up anglophone and and
started speaking french in the last
couple of years
um
from nothing um
i i was always proud of her linguistic
duality in canada um
to know that we had a linguistic
diversity in our country is something
that that strikes at the the very core
of what it means to be canadian and to
prove that
people who who have a distinct history
um can live alongside one another in
pursuit of a a better federation
is is something that i was always
inspired by um we need to be very
careful uh because we have huge
ambitions when it comes to growing
canada through our immigration system uh
if we don't manage uh the demographics
of that ambition
you could easily see how an increase in
the overall number will erode the
presence of francophones in canada and
say in acceptable
um
we need to think about what measures we
need to put in place i'll point to to
one that i'm pursuing now is to
um
flexibility
uh the the
the francophone
uh the competitors that
healthcare workers um
people who are going into francophone
communities where they'll have access to
school for their kids to childcare in
their language of choice um these are
the kinds of things we need to do
so i hesitate to
say uh let's jump to the to the the
target uh before i understand the
process of getting there
it's similar in a lot of ways to uh to
the pursuit of uh of reducing our
emissions on climate change targets are
important they're they're an essential
component to a plan but they are not in
and of themselves a plan
i want to satisfy myself the the best
possible measures to to uh protect uh
the french language and and uh the
french culture in canada because to me
it it's uh strikes at the very core of
what it is to be canadian
um
you say you want to put new programs in
place we look at the first number from
this year to a 22. it's
four percent of quebec it's a long way
up through point four point four
when can we expect a turnaround because
francophone are asking for a turnaround
when will we at least be able to go to
4.4 will it be this year
uh i i think you'll see an increase this
year um uh with uh with the numbers uh
and i think er er i wouldn't uh judge
too quickly early in the year there's
some unique things going on um
uh in our immigration system as we come
under the pandemic uh the inventory of
people includes folks who may have been
entitled to come and claim permanent
residency but for whatever reason chose
not to travel potentially because of the
public health situation
over the course of this year i expect
that you're going to see
an increase not just over last year was
a unique year with a pandemic that had
an impact on
on francophone uh resettlement in canada
but if you go back to the year prior we
were at 3.6 percent and i expect you'll
see a continued trajectory and we put in
plan a place uh in collaboration with uh
fcf over the last number of years to hit
it by 2023 uh so i think you'll see an
increase this year compared to two years
ago and then uh achieving the the uh the
target of 4.4 but by next year um the
i wouldn't read too much into the the
first uh 12 13 weeks of of this year in
terms of the outcomes you expect to see
uh because we do have uh new zealand
volunteer programs
the
if we put in place some of these extra
measures it'll make it easier for us to
make sure that we're pulling out
francophone newcomers who
uh who are already in the system and i
think that's going to make a huge
difference so i have a lot of confidence
that will uh exceed the level from two
years ago and put us on a pathway to hit
at least 4.4 next year and then we'll
look to continue to grow from there i
know you folks have to go but there's
only one person left in line would you
be willing to take one more question
yeah it's okay for me i'm looking around
the room if nobody's pulling me out of
the room i'm usually okay it's only
raffi yeah
cbc news you go ahead thanks very much
uh the first question is for high
commissioner although minister if you
want to jump in feel free as well
uh
more than a year ago now i believe you
put out a framework for how governments
can consider bringing in more climate
refugees and and specifically sort of
you know help out people trying to
escape from climate emergencies uh i
canada does not have one yet i believe
it's not the only country that doesn't
have one yet but can you speak to how
urgent it is for countries to be acting
on this
there are no such thing as climate
refugees let's
be very clear there are people
that
are forced to move
by
different causes climate plays a role in
that increasingly for example in the
sahel
but you know refugees are refugees there
is a definition and
refugees and i think it would be
risky to change that definition in in in
a world that um
in a political context in which we may
get a narrower definition as a as
opposed to a broader one what i think
needs to be done sorry i'm being
technical here but it's important is to
um
is to consider that many people that
flee for
in part at least for climatic reasons um
have protection needs that are covered
by many international legal instruments
and
and the global compact on refugees i
don't know if you were referring to that
recognizes that and encourages
government to consider this
um you know in most cases
there is a there's a bit of a
misconception there are people that flee
because of natural disasters you know
there's a flood there is a
a drought and they move to another areas
you know are there refugees or not these
are different from people fleeing war
but they have their own needs and
necessities and they need this needs to
be met
in most cases in case of natural
disasters people want to simply return
to their homes and reconstruct their
homes or be able to cultivate their
field so that's one set of issues very
frequently now and this is more
i think germane to your questions what
is happening is that climate becomes a
cause for conflict
um i am going in a few weeks to
chad
in west africa
um why because
chad is receiving
people from cameroon nearby country why
are these people fleeing they're fleeing
because there is a conflict between
different communities and why there is a
conflict between different communities
because climate change has deprived
those communities of basic resources and
when poor communities are deprived of
resources
very often there are tensions between
communities and this is causing an exit
are these refugees of course they're
refugees and are they covered by the
various conventions they are so it's a
complex issue this definition so what we
are telling
all countries is you know
this is not so much a resettlement issue
this is an issue of what do we do to
prevent these
movements this forced movement of
population and this is what i said
earlier in responding to another
question this is not simply a
humanitarian
response that is needed what is needed
here is look at the deep causes that
create this forced population movement
we need to addre fundamentally we need
to address the climate emergency
reducing emissions i mean i don't need
to give you all the all the all the list
of things that we know we should be
doing and we're not doing we're not
doing enough
but then there is also a development
element and there is an element of
conflict resolution that also needs to
be uh
strengthened so it's very complex i'm
sorry that i cannot give you a
straightforward answer but you know to
create a que a category of climate
refugee and say these people
this is not the right way to go i think
it's more complex than that and we do
have the instruments and we need the
resources to address it
look look
hard to follow that answer um
my look the very first time i ever got
involved with any kind of an official
organization i was seven years old in
grade two and i ran to become the vice
president of my environment club at my
elementary school
um i've literally been
a climate activist my entire life
marching in the streets for in my uh my
little little events in my hometown and
of course a few years ago i had the
honor to serve as parliamentary
secretary um
i i the point that i i really want to
drive home that the high commissioner
just made
is that if there's a vulnerable person
who's fleeing
their home country now
as a result of a multitude of factors
including climate change that person
should be eligible based on their
vulnerability um
whether you need to
have a branding exercise around climate
change i i i question
that said
this is going to become a bigger issue
so we need to be
watching very closely the impact of
climate on the movement of people
there will be some instances where
climate change leads to conflict that uh
causes people to become displaced there
will be other instances where there is a
natural disaster that demands action um
if things continue to worsen there may
be uh people who live with a
long-lasting
droughts
sea level rise etc
if they're vulnerable they're vulnerable
if they're vulnerable because of climate
they should qualify for refugee programs
to the extent we need to save specific
spaces
i i would just want to make sure that
we're not
taking away from other programs that
would
bring people based on their
vulnerability but certainly if someone's
fleeing because of climate-related
factors they must be eligible based on
their vulnerability not necessarily
solely because of uh
of the climate aspect the high
commissioner and the minister really do
have to go now so we'll have to cut it
off there thank you
uh
look uh
apologies i saw there was one more
question if we want to follow up
afterward i hate to leave people who
wanted to ask a question but we've got
an appointment so please don't don't be
shy to get in touch